[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISSY BEN-SHAUL: Thanks
for joining us today
to hear about automating
large-scale cloud migration.
It's a Google Cloud
with Velostrata.
We're very excited to be
here today for the first time
on stage as part of
the Google family
following the acquisition
of Velostrata by Google,
literally last month.
My name is Issy Ben-Shaul.
I'm the former CEO of
Velostrata, and the co-founder.
With me is Ady Degany,
former CTO and co-founder.
And going forward,
we're going to continue
to lead the Velostrata
team and product.
So I'm very excited about that.
So what you're going to hear
in the session today about
is how to effectively
migrate enterprise workloads
to Google Cloud at scale.
We're going to start with the
introduction of the product
and discuss technical
concepts behind it.
And then we'll dive in
into some of the automation
and scaling features
of the product.
We'll do a demo
that demonstrates
some of these capabilities
in live action,
follow with customer case
studies, and then summarize it.
An important note here
is that everything
that we discuss today
is generally available,
field-proven, and
ready to use at scale.
So before I start, I'll
do a show of hands.
How many of you in the audience
are planning or have already
engaged in some kind
of a cloud migration
from on-premise to
any public cloud?
That's a good showing, great.
And of those, how
many are working on,
let's say, large-scale
integration,
like hundreds of workloads or
more, production workloads?
Oh great.
So a pretty wide audience.
And you're in good company.
In fact, exploring
recent reports
about enterprise
cloud adoption, you
see the picture is pretty clear.
Enterprises are moving
away from on-premises
or even hosted data centers,
so-called private cloud,
into use of public cloud.
Even if you look
at, for instance,
those two columns
here, two years ago,
the investment in on-premises
versus public cloud
was similar.
And look what happened in the
last two years, huge difference
building up between the two.
Even if you look at another
interesting observation,
if you look at hybrid cloud
implementations, which
have been widely popular and
still are within enterprise,
you still see some decline in
favor of more public cloud use.
So if we dive in
a little bit more
into the cloud initiatives, we
find another interesting thing,
which is that the two top
most initiatives within cloud
initiatives are move more
workloads faster and deal
with the cost, optimizing
the costs of work
that are already in the cloud.
So why is that?
If you look back two years ago,
there has been a lot of focus
on first modernizing workloads,
optimizing for cloud usage,
and then moving on.
What CIOs are
starting to realize
last year is that these
modernization projects take
very long time, consume
a lot of resources.
In the meanwhile, cloud
integration projects
are being delayed.
And that delay,
in fact, means you
need to invest more in
infrastructure that is aging.
But you don't want to do it
because you want to move out.
So it's a perfect storm.
And many CIOs says,
OK, stop here.
I don't want to get rid of--
I want to get rid of
infrastructure management, move
infrastructure into service.
Let's just move it all.
And when they do that,
they do it and say,
well, let's modernize during
or after in a pragmatic manner.
But let's start get moving out.
Now, this is why
it's no surprise
that if you look--
according to Gartner,
a recent report, a quote,
"the fastest-growing segment
within the cloud business
is by far infrastructure
as a service, 36% growth,
year-over-year growth
over the last year, and
$40 billion-a-year business
in 2018.
So the bottom line
is enterprises
are moving fast and at scale.
But when you decide
to move at scale,
this introduces a whole
set of new challenges
that you need to
address to avoid
a bottleneck in the
migration process itself.
So it's one thing to
move dozens of workloads.
It's a whole
different story when
you need to deal with
thousands of workloads
that need to be moved.
How do we avoid this being the
next two, three years delay?
What do you deal
with multi-source.
When you move a
whole data center,
that includes virtual
machines, but it also
includes some physical servers.
What do you do with
previous deployments
you did to another cloud when
it was maybe the only option
available?
And now that there are more
options, maybe more cost
effective, how do you take at
mass large amount of workloads
that are say, at AWS,
and move them into GCP?
How do you deal with
complex applications that
are in the data center or SAP,
multi-tier complex workloads
with large databases which
have very strict downtime
requirements?
And then last but not least,
how do you mitigate the risk
in moving those workloads?
Many enterprise
customers have told us
that this is actually
a barrier to adoption
because if something
doesn't work,
I can't afford to
have downtime for days
without my application running.
So these are the
main challenges.
And Velostrata has been
designed from the ground up
to address these very
exact challenges.
It's an enterprise-grade,
field-proven solution that
actually focuses on
three major use cases--
number one, data
center migration,
horizontally moving whole data
centers into public cloud;
number two, the ability
to take, in large scale,
workloads that are
running in another cloud,
say, for instance, AWS, and
move it into Google Cloud;
and number three, a
specific focus on SAP.
You heard today in the keynote
the partnership with SAP.
We're actually taking it
to the next level in terms
of the migration and
working on SAP migration
both lift and shift as well
as lift and modernize, meaning
taking their existing
DB2, or Oracle,
or SQL relational
databases and move them
into HANA in conjunction with
moving them to the cloud.
So let's talk about the product.
How does it really work?
So there are two fundamental
concepts underlying
the Velostrata technology.
Number one, we actually
offer the ability
to take stateful, large
workloads running on-premises,
and literally within
minutes, have it-- run it
in the cloud, fully
operational, irrespective
of the size of the
data that is attached
to that workload or latency
that is across the web.
We call this streaming in
analogy to video streaming.
So you don't have to
download entire video
file to start watching it.
So in the same
idea, you don't have
to replicate all the
data to the cloud
to start computing
it or consuming it.
So the impact of that is that
from a downtime perspective,
you suffer a few
minutes of downtime
versus sometimes hours or days.
But it also allows you to start
your validation and migration
acceleration much faster
than other solutions.
The other fundamental important
concept is agentless design.
And what does this mean?
This means that we
don't install any agent
on the workload of the
actual machines that
are being migrated.
This turns out to be hugely
important for enterprises
because it means
that you don't have
to have intimate knowledge
of how the application works,
how to sync it up,
how to orchestrate
multi-tier applications.
And it turns out to
be a huge money saver
because it need much
less headcount and human
manual labor in doing it.
So those two agentless
streaming basically
means much, much faster
and much cheaper.
The other third element
is also being safer.
We'll talk about it.
So how does it really work?
Well, so the solution
starts with deploying
a virtual appliance, which
is right here in the data
source of the data
center or the cloud.
And then, there is an automatic,
on-demand and a [INAUDIBLE]
deployment of one or more
cloud extensions in the cloud
region of your choice.
It could be multiple
regions, et cetera.
Then let's say that, the
user said-- well, I'm sorry.
There's also a one-time set up.
You need to set up the VPN.
You need to set up the VPC.
And after this set-up
for the infrastructure,
you're ready to start
doing migration.
For instance, a user can
pick using the plugin
that we have into
the VMware Management
Console, the vCenter.
You can actually
pick one or more
of VMs or a whole application.
And say I want to
run it in the cloud.
When this happens,
our right here
back end appliance, knows
to take control over the VM,
shut it down in a
graceful manner,
take control over his
disk, and essentially
starts the boot
process in the cloud.
It establishes a data channel
with a cloud extension,
which in turn creates a
whole kind of a virtual disk
in the cloud that corresponds
to the remote storage,
and then starts the
boot process off
of that virtual
disk in the cloud.
Now, normally this
would be problematic
if it would be just simple
[INAUDIBLE] this way.
But fortunately, we've actually
implemented a very extensive
layer of WAN
optimization that makes
this work in as good performance
as on-prem and sometimes even
faster.
It includes caching.
For instance, all the operating
system images are very similar.
We see 95% to 98% similarity on
different or similar flavors.
And those can be
completely server locally.
For data that needs
to be transferred,
we offer network
deduplication, compression,
predictive prefetch based
on a number of heuristics,
read-ahead, and so
on and so forth.
So the vast majority of the
operations occur in the cloud.
We also commit all the
write operations locally
in the cloud using our
storage subsystem that
is highly resilient and
highly available in the cloud.
So the bottom line, within
minutes, you're up and running.
We also have an auto
adaptation layer
that knows to take the instances
and convert them automatically
to be able to run in the cloud--
Java injection,
licensing enforcements,
and so on and so forth.
So the bottom line is, you
have an instance running here
and magically a few minutes
later, it's running,
fully operational in the cloud.
Now, once we do that, in
the background, we kick--
actually in parallel--
data migration storage
to test all the call data
and start migrating it.
But important to
note, the workloads
are already running
operational in the cloud
while the data migrates.
You don't have to wait
for it to start running.
While doing this, the
system continues to operate.
And when data is fully
migrated, then you
can hit the detach operation
that essentially allows
you to cut the cord and
actually do the conversion
to completely cloud storage,
and then you're done.
Important to note that
while you are at stage two
and before you cut
the cord, so to speak,
you have the option to roll
back instantly within minutes
because we always keep all
the changes synced back
into the data center,
which is, again,
turns out to be very important.
One of our customers, Cardinal
Health, reported about 4%
of rollback typically
due to misconfigurations
of the network or other
elements that prevent it
from that workload to operate
in a proper manner in the cloud.
So knowing that you
have that allows
you to go at scale
without having
to worry about what would happen
if that workload didn't work,
so very important.
So overall, again,
I showed you how
do we take a workload that
within literally minutes,
have it operational
in the cloud.
And now we'll turn and
see how does this work?
We need to deal with hundreds
of workloads at the same time.
Turn it over to Ady.
ADY DEGANY: Guys, thanks for
joining us for the session.
So I'll talk about the features
that really make migration
at scale work.
And one of the
things that we wanted
to ensure that when we
go to the enterprise,
we can fit into
the way things are
being done in this data
center today and augment that
with additional
capabilities for automation
so that you can weave
it into your practices,
whether it's workflow
management or orchestration.
So just a show of
hands, how many of you
are using VMware on-prem?
That's great.
So, we saw a lot of
customers making investments
over the last 10, 15 years
in their VMware environment.
And that goes beyond
just the compute.
It goes into operations
management, and monitoring,
and health management.
And what we wanted to do is
really take that environment
and augment it in
a natural way so
that it will reduce
the learning curve
of moving these
workloads to the cloud
or using the clouds in
tandem with that environment
in the hybrid scenario.
So we've built the
management of our solution
with tight integration
into the vSphere platform,
into the vSphere
vCenter Web Client,
augmenting and extending the
existing objects that we're
going to deal with,
which is a virtual data
center and the virtual machine.
So in the demo that
we'll show in a moment,
you'll see how that
looks like and work.
Now, when it comes to
large scale, of course,
we're not expecting
users to go and click
on each VM out of your
1,500 VM inventory
that you have in that cluster.
And this is where we built a
set of tools for automation.
So we have a published REST
API that you can go and use
with your favorite
orchestrator, whether it's
vRealize automation, or
whether it is Ansible,
or another solution of choice.
We also offer a
PowerShell module
for scripting
integration, as well as
a built-in mechanism
for orchestration
of the large-scale migration.
And this is a feature we
call the Automation Runbook.
The Automation Runbook really
gives you out-of-the-box
experience of migrating
large sets of VMs,
and not just individual servers,
but giving you the ability
to describe full stacks,
full application stacks.
It can be anywhere from
tens and hundreds of VMs,
as well as controlling the
information on how they're
going to be configured
in the cloud, what
security groups they're
going to go into,
what tagging strategy
you want to apply.
You can select what instance
steps you are going to use,
what the disk drives, how
they're going to be called,
as well as the ordering
between the VMs
when you're moving the
different tiers in that stack.
And we'll see that
all in the demo.
The Automation Runbook comes
with a very simple UI to use.
It also comes with a
REST API, so you, again,
can tie it into your automation
mechanisms and practices.
So we'll dive into
that in more detail,
also in the context of
the migration practice
and how to implement that.
Now, one of the things
that come up very often
is that when you're deploying
in a VMware environment,
you get built-in
over-subscription
of your cluster resources.
So it's very easy to go and
say I want a 12 CPU machine
with 24 gigabyte of RAM.
And even if it
doesn't use it, you're
not paying for it any extra.
But when it comes
to the cloud, you
get SLAs around the
system performance
and the types of
machines that you get,
but you're also paying for it.
So a very important element is
to properly size your machines
before you migrate them.
Now, when we deploy in
a VMware environment,
we have the tight integration
that I talked about.
And part of that
tight integration
is also the ability to monitor
your workloads as they operate.
So while they're running,
we will monitor them,
we will identify their
utilization of resources.
And that will help us
provide recommendation
what instance type to choose.
Later on, of course,
after migration,
you get the benefits
of the automatic sizing
recommendations that are
provided on an ongoing basis
once running in GCP.
And of course, for the
sizing recommendation,
we'll also take into
consideration specific GCP
features, feature like
custom instance types
is a very important feature.
It allows you to
select exactly the size
of machines that you
are going to need,
as well as the consideration
of sustained use discounts
into the cost decisions.
One feature that
comes very handy
when you're migrating
a lot of machines
is the ability to validate,
validate your plan,
validate your practice,
validate your configuration.
And when it comes to
critical workloads,
sometimes you want
to do it, you want
to do the validations
before you actually
touch your application.
So we have the
ability to snapshot
an entire set of machines that
are running in an application
stack and bring up a thin
clone of that stack in GCP
in an isolated VPC, or in
isolated network subnet
so there's no conflict
with your on-prem,
and allow it to
validate your procedure,
validate the configuration,
validate performance.
And you can do that in a click
of a button or an API call.
And you can do that without
waiting for any data
to transfer.
And this is the beauty of
the streaming technology
that Issy mentioned earlier.
Now, when we go into enterprise
environments, in many cases,
they were built to control--
there were mechanisms
built to control
a lot of the incoming traffic.
But when you're migrating,
traffic is outgoing.
And this is where
people typically
struggle in identifying
how much bandwidth they
need to allocate.
How do they govern
the bandwidth that
is used for migration
versus the other SLAs
that they need to provide
to their organization
because the users are
not moving to the cloud?
So, in order to eliminate
the complexity associated
with deciding how
much bandwidth do I
give this VM when it migrates,
or that VM when it migrates?
And what do I do when I have
a data center that now I
want to distribute
across multiple regions
because I have that
capability with the cloud,
and I want to bring the
workflows closer to the users?
So this is where we've built a
governed bandwidth management
mechanism that enables you with
a simple setting at the site
level, decide how much you
want to allocate to migration.
And the system will do
its work automatically.
You don't need to
split it manually
between the different workloads
and the number of workers
that are migrating.
Worth mentioning some additional
enterprise-grade capabilities.
First of all, security,
encryption, network security,
and network policies.
The solution has
been built to be
able to work within your
private address space.
There is no need for you to
open internet access for it.
You can operate it
completely within your VPN
and your private address space.
And we support features
like private Google access
so that you don't need to expose
more than you were planning to.
We also support features
like working behind NAT,
working behind HTTP proxies.
So anything that
you are familiar
with from your
environment is something
that we can work with.
And you don't need to go
through painful changes
to your existing infrastructure.
Now, measurement monitoring
is an important piece.
How do you know that
you are maximizing
your available resources?
Can you migrate more?
Can you migrate faster?
Is the application getting
the performance it needs?
This is all something that
requires a lot of telemetry.
And a lot of you know from
VMware deployments on-prem
that monitoring is a difficult
environment to manage.
So we went on and
built essentially
a Velostrata-hosted service
that will perform the log
aggregation,
telemetry collection,
and will give you the results
processed and analyzed
into your vSphere environment
as readily available graphs
without the need to beef
up the deployment on-prem.
So before we delve into the
demo, a little bit on migration
practices and some insights
that we have learned together
with our partners
and our customers
in the process of migrating
thousands of machines.
First of all, it's
very important
to determine ahead of
time what is the inventory
that you want to move.
What do you want to move first?
What do you want to move next?
Coordinate in advance with
the application owners.
the infrastructure team,
with the networking team.
Identify the workloads that
you don't want to move,
so you don't waste time on them.
Identify workloads that
were originally problematic
and maybe remained
on physical machines
because they couldn't
be virtualized before.
This allows you to plan ahead.
And planning ahead is
important because when
you want to migrate
a lot of machines
when you want to achieve
scale, the best practice
we've seen working
well is to do that
by establishing a pipeline.
Make sure that you always have
machines identified and ready
to move.
Create that pipeline, and
you can migrate even hundreds
of machines per day.
And for that discovery
process, we've
been working with our
various partners, partners
like RISC Networks
and Cloudamize,
and others that are joining in.
And we continue to work
with them to optimize.
And they can also integrate
well with our Automation Runbook
and REST APIs.
And if you are not integrated
and you want to be,
then this is all public APIs,
and we'll be happy to share.
Now, automation is key.
And we'll show some of
it as part of the demo.
This is a case study.
These are actual measurements
from a customer project.
This is a customer
that has migrated
several hundreds of machines.
And you can see as we were
working with the customer
to identify the best practice
for them, to build the team,
to build the migration
practice itself,
we converged with them
on an agile approach.
The agile approach allowed
them to increase their velocity
eight to 10 times, which
means at some point,
they were able to migrate
about 150 machines in one day.
And what is that sprint approach
or agile approach looking like?
If you have a team,
or you structure
a set of teams that are
dealing with different aspects
of your environment, you
can create this pipeline
where you spend one
week identifying
the inventory for
the next sprint,
working with the
application owners
to schedule the migration,
to schedule the validations,
and then prepare the Automation
Runbook, validate it.
The Automation Runbook is
a self-documenting plan,
so you don't need
to do that twice.
And then go into the next
week, and you execute the plan.
The machines migrate and
are live within typically
just a couple hours.
So you can have your
application orders come in
on a predictable schedule,
perform the validation,
and hand over to the users.
And after a set of trial period,
you can decide to cut the cord
and complete the migration.
Or if any issues came up
and they are unexpected,
leverage our rollback
feature to be
able to move the machines
to operate back on-prem
with full consistent state.
So this is an
example of a sprint
that we're migrating about
70-plus machines in one go.
And what you can see here in the
graph is that the blue line--
and don't catch
me on the color--
is the number of machines
that we're running
and how long it took for
them to actually run and be
live in the cloud.
And you can see that
within about two hours,
the entire set of machines
across all the migration groups
and tiers were up and running.
Within the next day
and a half, the data
was migrated in the background.
But that doesn't
prevent the application
from running,
which means you can
be live in the cloud in just
minutes regardless of the size.
So we'll switch over
to a quick demo.
We didn't have much time.
We had a lot to
show, so we're going
to show a time-sped
recorded demo.
We have a showcase
downstairs that you
can go in and play with
these different scenarios
interactively.
So first we'll start with
the vCenter integration.
And I'll go through
that quickly.
So this is the well-known
vSphere Web Client user
interface.
And you can see the
integration through extension
of the virtual machine object.
So you can select a virtual
machine, right click on it,
and you'll get the
Velostrata menu.
Or you have several
options for the migration.
Two notable ones
are the Run In Cloud
option, which allows you
to take any workload,
run it in the cloud in
minutes without having
to move the storage.
This is good if you
want to try things.
If you want to test
how your machine will
work on a machine with
four terabytes of RAM,
how will it work with on a
machine with 128 CPUs, how
will it work with a GPU or a TPU
that you never had access to,
you can do that without
having to resort to building
your application from scratch.
And regardless of how
much data you have,
it will be accessible using
a streaming mechanism.
The second notable
option is Migrate.
You decided that you want
to move, let's do that.
So we'll click on
Migrate, and you'll
get a very simple wizard
built into the system.
You'll select your
target, your target VPC.
target machine type.
And this is where you can
see the different rightsizing
recommendations coming in,
whether you want the machine
that best fits the current
provision size on VMware,
or whether you want
one that is based
on the actual utilization,
which, in this case,
is very low utilization.
Then you'll select
the storage policy.
And we can talk
about that offline.
Select the disc
type, and that's it.
You're ready to go.
So let's click Finish.
And now we'll see
the integration
into the vSphere interface
from a monitoring perspective.
There is a portlet that
shows up for that machine.
So we're not creating
a new object.
We're not creating-- you
are not losing the admin
context for that machine.
And as you can see, within
the vSphere environment,
you can see the status
of the machine running
in the cloud and the
status of its migration.
So this machine has over
a terabyte worth of disks,
about three disks.
And it is up and
running in 11 minutes.
Another thing you
can see in this
is the integration-- the
further integration with it
into vSphere, which is
integration into events,
and issues, and
alarms so it will all
propagate into your vRealize
operation management.
11 minutes over one
terabyte, it took me
longer to upload the video.
So let's see what happens if
things don't work as well.
Maybe there's a quota issue.
Maybe the application
owner is not
ready to come in and
do the validation,
so you need to rollback.
Rolling back is as easy
as moving to the cloud.
So this machine
has been going on.
It's running live.
Storage is migrating
in the background
as you can see in the bar here.
And we decided that we
want to move it back.
So another right
click on that VM.
And we'll select
the Run On-premises.
And that's it, just
a single click.
And what you'll see is that
the system will be back on-prem
in just a few minutes.
Since the system is
running in the cloud,
we constantly
synchronize the changes
that was happening in
the last few minutes
or up to certain
change capacity.
And we'll replicate
it back on-prem,
to the disks on-prem so you can
move back at any point in time.
And if you have backup
happening on-prem
it will always backup the
latest version of that machine
while it's running in the cloud.
So this is the integration
into the web UI
kind of tasting that.
Let's talk about the
Runbook Automation.
Obviously, when you
have 1,500 machines,
and when you have stacks
of 30 machines or more,
you are not going to do
multi-select or do that
manually.
So this is where a
Runbook Automation
feature comes into play.
And we'll start with a simple
multi-tier application.
This is the SugarCRM setup.
And you can see this
application running on-prem,
on the VMware side.
We'll even go and
create some new state,
add some data just
to demonstrate
that you can migrate
immediately without having
to deal with complex
synchronization and cut over.
So let's migrate
that application.
First, we'll create a runbook.
To create the runbook, you
go into the Velostrata web
interface, select your
source, vSphere or AWS.
Additional sources
will come later.
You'll select your source
data center or virtual data
center where your inventory
resides, and the target cloud.
We are going to get
the runbook exported
in CSV format, so very easy
to work with in a spreadsheet
editor.
So let's take that
inventory that was exported.
A lot of information is
already included there.
What's the
configuration on-prem?
What's the naming as well
as default selections
for the target?
And then next thing we'll do
is filter out that inventory
just to the set that we
want to migrate in this run.
And we will also create order.
This allows you to take
a multi-tier application,
define the different
components in each tier,
identify the order between
them, and also identify
service probes.
So when a certain
tier is coming up,
you can probe that the
service is available
before you start up the
next set of VMs in the tier.
So let's take that
CSV file and save it.
Next thing we want to do is
apply rightsizing to that.
So we'll take the CSV file that
we filtered, we'll input it
into the recommendation
engine, and we'll
get rightsizing
recommendations built
into the entire set of machines
that are in that spreadsheet.
We'll select the
relevant recommendations,
copy them over to the
target instance type
that we want to use.
And the runbook is ready.
Now, as you can see, the runbook
is a self-documenting plan,
which means you don't have
to take all that information
and keep it in
other inventories,
in other repositories.
We'll take that
runbook, and you can
apply additional
information there
like your tagging strategy.
Define your labels, and
they will be applied
when the machines are moving.
So let's go and start
the migration job.
Now, the migration is done
on a full set of machines.
To verify the operation,
the progress, et cetera,
you go into the
monitoring page, and this
is where you will see
the state of each VM
that is currently migrating.
Effectively what you will see
the system change your state
as they go through coming up
live, transferring the storage,
and ready to detach.
When it's ready to
detach, the migration
effectively has completed.
So let's look at
the application.
The application is now online.
So what we have in the
showcase downstairs
is also a demo of
additional scenarios
moving from AWS to GCP,
using the Automation Runbook.
And again, the
Automation Runbook
is fully available both
in the UI and in REST API,
so you can tie it to
your own orchestration
on your own
automation procedures.
ISSY BEN-SHAUL: Thanks, Ady.
So with the remaining
time we have,
we want to see how all this
great technology translates
into actual business
benefits for the customers
through some case studies
from actual customers
that we've deployed
our solution with.
So we've done numerous
deployments of thousands of VMs
from on-premises
to public cloud.
For example, we have one
public sector company in the UK
that actually has been running
into issues with respect
to having to vacate their hosted
data center within six months.
They were way, way behind
timelines and budget.
We were introduced
into that scenario.
And within pretty much six
weeks and about 10x faster,
completed the migration in time.
And there's, as you can
see, different segments,
interesting segments that
we've been working in.
Health care is one, financial,
oil and energy, and few others.
And what comes across is really
three major benefits-- one,
significant time savings; number
two, significant cost savings;
and number three, safe journey.
And this is all what
you see in our solution.
Let's take specifically
Cardinal Health,
which has gone through
an interesting journey.
They have come to the conclusion
that they need to, again,
decommission the data centers,
do a move on [? all ?] [? in ?]
of several data
centers to the cloud.
They started the
journey actually
with a different
cloud, AWS actually,
and moved with Velostrata
quite a bit of workloads again.
They had time constraints.
They have budget constraints.
And basically decided,
after selecting--
or basically testing
a few solutions,
to go with Velostrata.
And we were able to
migrate about 1,000 servers
within six months.
By the way, not all of
it is actual migration
as Ady pointed out.
There's discovery, there's
planning, there's assessment,
getting alignment from
the [INAUDIBLE] owners.
All this come into play.
But a rough-- a cadence
of 100 servers per week
or 5,000 servers per
year is something
we were seeing
consistently happening
with a lot of our customers
using our solution.
And then midway through their
[INAUDIBLE] journey into one
cloud, they decided--
made a business
decision to switch,
to go to another cloud,
this time to Google Cloud.
And during that
time, they also used
Velostrata to actually
make all that transition
very effectively.
And actually as
we speak, they're
moving hundreds of
machines per week with us.
And you can see
savings of millions
of dollars due to
the fact that they
didn't have to deal with
nearly as much head count
as they would have needed
with other solution.
We're running a little
bit short in time,
so I'll just to mention one
more, which is another energy
company that we work with.
Again, were using
a different vendor.
It's the blue line or
the blue color there.
And the trajectory
of their completion
was two and 1/2 years for
completing their migration.
With a 5x acceleration that
we offered in our solution
after they chose
us, they basically
compressed the time to six
month for the same amount
of workloads.
And not only that,
but they also realized
about a million dollars of
savings due to the reduced head
count that was required
due to the simplicity
and automation of the solution.
So in quick summary,
this is a time
for enterprises
to make the move,
not stay behind competition.
If you want to move
at scale, I think
Google Cloud is your choice.
And we strongly believe that
Velostrata is a right solution.
For a time perspective,
you get very quick downtime
or very short downtime,
5x labor savings,
or 80%, 5x acceleration
compared to any other solution
out there, and very easy
solution to work with.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]